bonjour verra merci d'être avec nous
alors que faut-il retenir du discours du
président russe
bonjour amira pour la russie les pays du
g20 doivent reconnaître mutuellement les
certificats nationaux de vaccination
un appel lancé par vladimir poutine lors
de son intervention visioconférence au
sommet de rome dans son allocution le
président russe a aussi abordé le
problème de l'inaccessibilité des
vaccins pour plusieurs pays ou encore de
la question de la disponibilité du
vaccin rue spoutnik les déjà utilisé
dans plusieurs dans plus de 70 pays du
monde pour les partenaires de la russie
vladimir poutine a aussi souligné qu'il
était d'accord avec son homologue
français emmanuel macron au sujet du
rôle accru de l'organisation mondiale de
santé dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire je vous propose d'écouter
malgré
les efforts qui ont été faits notamment
pour l'accès aux parents aux vaccins
et encore beaucoup de pays qui sont
privés de cet accès je considère qu'il
ya une concurrence déloyale qui déloyale
qui est mise en place
malhonnête et il ya le problème de
reconnaissance des vaccins bien la
question
qui est que qu'il faudrait que l'om s
accélère la reconnaissance des vaccins
sur leur sécurité leur efficacité leur
fiabilité et plus cela plus vite cela
refait plus vite nous pourrons reprendre
une activité économique normale et
notamment pour le secteur touristique
vladimir poutine n'a pas non plus manqué
d'évoquer la crise énergétique en
soulignant que la stabilité des cours
dépendent et de tous les acteurs du
marché écoutez
il ya la question de l'accès aux sources
d'énergie et ce que je voulais ajouter à
ce qui a été dit c'est que
de la stabilité sur ce marché dépend de
la stabilité d'une manière générale de
tous les participants de ce marché de
tous les acteurs il s'agit ici de mettre
en place une politique à long terme avec
des discussions approfondies pragmatique
sur
à partir de considérations purement et
communes chers collègues dans l'ensemble
le gage de la reprise de l'économie à
long terme l'augmentation du niveau de
vie de la population
ça veut dire que il faut mettre en place
l'idée
conditions de travail hors de toute
discrimination
et c'est là
le l'objectif du travail du g20 je
rappelle que les dirigeants du g20 sont
actuellement réunis à rome pour parler
de la situation sanitaire et de la
relance post que vide de l'économie
mondiale
merci verra pour toutes ces précisions